of Phoenix leaders promise action after
facing thousands of angry protesters at
a public meeting community members lined
up at a local church last night to
respond to a video showing police
officers confronting a couple and their
two small children Jeff the gaze has
some of the very heated discussion you
guys I put fear in my life for more than
two hours people in Phoenix unleash
their anger y'all do y'all job and my
animal a monster I'm a human being they
are upset at the police department over
recent conduct issues that have drawn
national attention one of those
incidents happen in May when officers
drew their guns on a family after a
report of shoplifting Trayvon Ames and
Aisha Harper's say the incident left
their family traumatized I have
nightmares of barrow's pointed on my
face and I just think how I couldn't
save my daughters I don't know what was
going on we are here to listen we are
here to come back with this community we
are here to make change chief Jerry
Williams apologized and said change
starts with a community-wide rate Nelson
says police drew their guns on his
family when they were pulled over for
their vehicle displaying a stolen plate
the chief later apologized in a letter
saying that Nelson was a victim of
license plate theft my son is
traumatized my son asks me the other day
when I feed them up from back here you
know he asked me a cop or behind us he
said daddy is the cop I'll take you to
jail to kill you my daughter said that
the police killed you who's going to be
my daddy
police say the stop involving Nelson's
family was high risk but in compliance
with policy there is a protest planned
for tonight after a City Council meeting
to demand the officers involved in the
latest incident who are on desk duty be
fired Anthony yes the gays thank you
very much Jeff